what's going on guys this is Rob and
Hulk is fighting Thanos so welcome back
to issue number two as always if you
guys need to get caught up you'll find a
link to the Thanos playlist at the end
of this video but for a little bit of a
refresher here Thanos has basically
launched an attack against Earth
specifically Fresno and the Illuminati
have essentially assembled in order to
rescue a girl named Roberta who has no
clue what it is that's going on right
now now I hypothesized who this girl was
and why she matters and why Thanos is
hunting her because he is in particular
looking for her he doesn't know it's her
but he's just looking for a person and
so a lot of it's just kind of left to
thanos's ability to just sort of deduce
the situation the fact that he's here on
Earth looking for a person the
illuminatti and really the superheroes
most likely know who she is they'll go
to rescue her which is exactly what they
did and all Thanos has to do is
essentially follow them which is kind of
doing because what he's doing is
basically laying waste to this entire
city of Fresno and in fact what he had
done using a ship was actually pull
Fresno off of Earth and out into space
now two things number one as I
understand it there's nothing in Fresno
so I have no clue why in the world he's
attacking this place and number two as I
understand it folks in California
wouldn't mind if Fresno disappeared off
the face of the planet and was just
taken into space I think he'd be more
apt to say if he did it to Detroit I'm
sorry for all you guys who live in
Detroit David cage my bad bro but still
it's just one of those things right what
you end up getting here with this
Illuminati team though and like we
mentioned in the last video they have
blue Marvel Now historically speaking
right like the Illuminati consists of
Black Panther and Reed Richards Doctor
Strange all those different guys
blackbolt for reasons it makes sense to
nobody at all because that guy sucks but
blue Marvel being here this guy's a
Powerhouse right this guy is one of the
various analogues of Superman in Marvel
Comics The Dude is a Hos and so one of
the things that I also want to point out
here is that I initially thought this
story took place in like an alternate
universe it doesn't because there's a
point where Iron Man's talking to Emma
Frost and he says are you sure you don't
want to stay in Disguise given
everything else that's going on right
now we're given a little asteris and
they reference fall of X so this takes
place in the main Marvel Universe at the
time that fall of X is happening which
is kind of cool right it's not a huge
deal doesn't have a massive impact on
anything but it is cool that we get that
little bit of continuity there and so
what ends up happening is two things
first the uminati basically end up
making a phone call to bring somebody in
the second thing they do is they
basically have blue Marvel travel to the
ship of Thanos and then incapacitate The
Shield that's pulling Fresno out of
really Earth's orbit into space so it
can kind of be returned of course and
the hope is that they can put Fresno
exactly where it's supposed to be right
because you can't just deactivate the
shield it'll go crashing down into the
Earth wherever it happens to be over the
Earth as it's being pulled away now
here's a cool thing and this is where
Hulk comes into play as they start
having this conversation right the
question is okay I thought we were
trying to save Fresno not further
destroy it and the response of Emma
Frost is think about it though it's
probably the right move read the
response of Iron Man let's call him and
where Roberta right this girl who's just
there and has no clue what's going on
she asked the question like call who
Emma Frost is like the big stick now
here's one thing that I do want to point
out here in Marvel Comics when it com
comes to the Incredible Hulk there's
only been very few times where he's
actually fought Thanos like in a true
fight right the two of them just going
toe to- toe but in the Hulk versus
Thanos Story by Jim Starin where the two
of them never actually physically fought
it was literally Thanos fighting Hulk in
like the mindscape right so it's like
the most clickbait name for a comic ever
there was a story in Marvel Comics
written by Jim Starin where Thanos had
literally stated that he was always
fearful of fighting the Hulk well not
really fearful but it was a fight he
always avoided just because of how
incredibly strong the Hulk can be and
how difficult it is to even just injure
him in a base State the longer the fight
goes on the angrier he's going to get
the stronger he's going to get and the
less of a chance that Thanos is going to
have right the quicker that Hulk is
going to help Thanos finish with all his
living and so there's a lot of kind of
back and forth on this right like a lot
of back and forth like we don't really
know if we should do this like this guy
is just kind of an unknown entity but
the issue here is that Thanos is a guy
where he's just such a heavy hitter they
need someone who's comparable and so
because of this they do momentarily
debate the idea of a backup plan in case
like things go sideways with the Hulk or
if by some unforeseen circumstance
Thanos manages to kill the Hulk but the
reality is they just don't really have
time they kind of have to think of it on
the Fly and so what you get is blue
Marvel flying to the ship and then
basically busting into this place in
order to try to incapacitate the shield
now as a testament to Blue Marvel's and
intelligence by himself what this guy
does is not only incapacitate the
shields but also precisely place Fresno
right back to where it was supposed to
be right so it is pretty smart that he
was able to do it on his own without any
help from Reed Richards or anybody else
now to the moment you've all been
waiting for you get this amazing moment
right where Iron Man asked Doctor
Strange did you call him right and
strange says I did in a sense he wasn't
happy to hear from me we may be on our
own right because remember one of the
last times that Hulk heard from Steven
strange in any meaningful way was during
World War Hulk right when like Steven
strange manifested the power of Z and
tried to kill the Hulk right so again
like the Illuminati reaching out to Hulk
that's not something he's keen on right
Planet Hulk World War Hulk that's all
him versus the Illuminati but at the end
of the day Stephen Strange says now keep
this in mind Tony this throne's more
mystical componentry can be quite a
challenge and I've never had the chance
to to really get a look up close the
response of Iron Man let me see if I can
give you that chance now this is where
Thanos responds right Thanos says you I
do not believe an Iron Man nor a
sorcerer Supreme pose any threat to my
devotion I ripped myself from the lip of
an event horizon all to find the one who
must be mine I'll not be dissuaded in my
quest now of course what he's talking
about here is what we referenced I want
to say we talked about it during Jud day
but the Thanos had basically been
dropped into a gravity well right he was
dropped into a black hole and seemingly
locked away forever the guy got himself
out right cuz that's just the power of
Thanos right well he was kind of rescued
SL got himself out but still he escaped
right and that's how Thanos ended up
returning post that story it was away
for Marvel to remove him from the
landscape and just kind of allow stories
to be told without fans wanting to see
Thanos all the time because the MCU had
basically killed him off of course
Thanos is too popular to just be removed
hence the reason why he's back but
that's when the Hulk shows up here right
at the end of the day like yes Steven
strange is really powerful the guy's
Powers just change like the wind
depending on who's writing the story and
Iron Man's cool but the guy is no match
for Thanos like it's just not going to
happen especially not in the comics but
in the middle of this whole conflict
these guys are doing everything they can
right see in strange is like Thanos I'm
warning you leave Fresno at once right
and it's just like oh strange I have yet
to complete my most sacred errand and
where Doctor Strange tries to conjure
the Crimson bands of C act Thanos
immediately overcomes him and then shuts
him down now this is Thanos playing
smart right because Thanos is kind of
like okay so here's the thing with this
level of power this guy has right like
he needs to speak in order to conjure
spells for the most part he doesn't
necessarily have to but even within the
doctor strange Mythos it's similar to
Harry Potter in the sense that casting
magic without using words is a very
dangerous Gambit and some of the most
magical spells and most powerful spells
require you to actually speak the
incantations out loud taking that
ability Away by just knocking him out
immediately makes it possible for Thanos
to avoid him and that's when you have
Hulk who appears he says you can SWAT
away puny Iron Man and smash a magic man
but can you stop a Hulk and so for one
of the very few times in Marvel Comics
you see these guys go toe to- toe now
here's where things get murky and I want
to know your all's opinion about this
right so Thanos responds right he says I
have no time for this banner I will not
let you stand in my way and of course
says you know like Banner's not here
it's only Hulk right Hulk will deal with
you yada y yada Doctor Strange wakes
back up basically starts Conjuring
mystical Powers again and between doctor
strange and Hulk working together
they're able to at the very least hold
Thanos off but Thanos is able to hold
his own against all of them right and he
even tells Steven strange one cannot
speak spells if one cannot breathe right
just like but literally using his cloak
to quite literally choke him with it
right Hulk's like you know let him go
and that kind of a thing but Thanos is
really just kind of toying with these
guys if we're being honest and keeps
asking like where is this girl now I
want to know your all's take on this
right like is Hulk a guy where in the
initial outset of the conflict Thanos
would be able to hold his own and
potentially toy with him or do you think
the base level of Hulk's strength when
he first shows up on the battlefield
before he's in like just some
ridiculously enraged state if even then
he's too much for Thanos I want to know
your all's thought on that right because
it is a really interesting question this
story is written by Christopher cwell
this guy knows what he's doing right so
I'm really curious to see how you all
feel about that but at the end of the
day the goal of the Illuminati is to
basically just keep Roberto safe from
Thanos right now that Fresno is back on
Earth itself and the shields of thanos's
ship which basically created a kind of
barrier around the city or gone they can
just sort of get her to wherever they
need to get her right so like the clock
is on right the clock's Counting down
before the Illuminati whisk this girl
away and now Thanos has to hunt the
entire world for this girl as opposed to
just a city out there in California
somewhere but even then like the fight
between Thanos and Hulk it's by no means
like Thanos you know just like crushing
The Hulk and swatting him away like he
did during Infinity Gauntlet when he had
like The Gauntlet in his hand and all
the powers that came with it right it's
like Hulk who's literally countering
this guy punching him sending him flying
like that kind of thing it is cool right
so it's entirely a really interesting
fight between them it's not just you
know Hulk getting steamrolled like a
jobber that's not really what's
happening but the fact remains here the
Illuminati are not able to overcome this
guy now in one of the weirdest
moments in Marvel Comics and I don't
know why Christopher cwell decided to do
this outside of the fact that it's
probably one of the most awesome things
that any of us have ever seen Thanos
realizes the Illuminati are getting
Roberta out of town so this guy tears
the top off of a truck Hot wires it and
then drives to where Roberta's
at Thanos Hotwire is a truck I just I I
need to say that like it just needs to
be said out loud some people are going
to be like herpy derp derp that's
ridiculous Thanos would never do it and
that's what makes it awesome because
Thanos hotwired a truck which is just a
ridiculous concept but it sounds and
just looks amazing now here's a cool
thing right Thanos just comes barreling
into this parking lot where Roberta's at
right and it's just like there she is
now emmafrost steps up with her Diamond
form and I guess that's all kind of cool
and everything right super powerful
telepath or secondary mutation is that
she can turn herself into a diamond
whatever but at the end of the day she
gets a little full of herself and uses
her telepathy to kind of hold Thanos
back which you could do right Emma Frost
is one of the most powerful telepaths in
the entirety of the Marvel Universe like
on a universal level not just on Earth
but like throughout the whole universe
she's that op but she gets too big for
her britches Thanos swats her away right
just basically knocks her unconscious
and sends her flying and when that
happens he seizes Roberta right and he
was like you will get in the vehicle now
right because what spells less sketchy
than just some giant purple guy who's a
demig god Venton annihilating anything
and everything that he possibly can
forcing you into a sketchy vehicle right
like I mean it's just it's one of
these one of just these ridiculous
things but Roberta doesn't understand
what's happening right and she's like
are you going to kill me and his
response no I'm not going to kill you I
only need you to remember who you truly
are and she was like no like my name's
Roberto right Roberto Marshall he's like
no you are my greatest love my reason
for being you are mistress death I
called it at the end of the last video I
told you guys that's who it was this is
who it is make sure you guys click the
playlist to get caught up on the Thanos
series and I will catch you all later
peace